welcome to the Church of what's
happening now the church is brought to
you by me undies me and these makes feel
good on these your butt would be proud
to wear there'll be the most comfortable
pair underwear you're ever own
with tons of styles and patterns to
choose from for both men and ladies me
and these will have the perfect fit for
any personality
I got about thousands of them I love my
got all different colors when I wear
them with a white D people ask me why do
you have butterflies and underwear I
could care less than the softest that
the cutout it doesn't get controls the
sweat in your nutsack they're tremendous
do me a favor to get 20% off the best
and throw off this underwear and socks
you'll ever own free shipping at 100%
satisfaction guarantee
go to me on these comm slash Joey that's
me undies comm slash Joey number 2 are
you looking do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidate
are you hiring you know that quality
highest keep your business moving
forward but you also know it could take
a lot of time to find the right
candidates for your job with zip
recruiter you can post your job to over
100 web leading job boards with just one
click so you can rest easy knowing your
job is being seen by the right
candidates what I'm going to do is this
find out today why zip recruiter has
been used by grown businesses of all
sizes and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now my listeners can
post jobs on zip recruiter you ready
free that's right free just go to zip
recruiter comm slash Church that's zip
recruited comm slash Church one more
time it's free
zip recruiter comm slash Church you're
gonna be happy that you did take this
meal Lee
you
what's happened you bad [ __ ]
Uncle Joe here had a beautiful Monday
night in Los Angeles
Lisa ATS here what up G I'm doing good
Janet Jackson was actually my like first
concert at like fifth grade or something
my dad got tickets to like the tea that
used to be the it's called the TD Garden
now I used to used to cut the
fleetcenter and we're up we're up in the
way back I think it was I don't think
I'd even hardly saw Celtics and then all
ruined it but now it's called the garden
it's again called the garden but uh yeah
she's like it I almost wish I could have
seen something like she's part of a
dynasty because that her family is a
dynasty it's you know it's crazy that I
saw them I mean I'm a little younger
than Michael maybe by a year or two
really he's dead but I still remember
walking on Times Square and making my
godfather buy me the ABC yeah I mean I
stood him to bring it home and listening
to it and sing other dancing like a
[ __ ] lunatic that night well it was a
different back then because now you
there's like a lot of kids TV shows and
there's kids on online but back then
were there like child stars like your
age oh alright so TV had three [ __ ]
channels Ryan when I came from Cuba
three hit TV had three channels and you
had Telemundo and Univision yeah I'm
saying so that's that's that child stars
I don't really like the Osmonds remember
we had like one time with the Osmonds
and the Jacksons and then you know you
had a individual little guys that one
team beat David Cassidy and [ __ ] like
that that's who was around when I was
around him you know I didn't really look
at [ __ ] little boys weak right now
[ __ ] idea I want to thank the people
at Tampa and the surrounding areas Miami
for coming out for the temporary problem
I had a [ __ ] blast like I said some
guy brought me a [ __ ] Black Sabbath
paranoid album the covers busted up but
the [ __ ] album's in great shape my
friend Gino brought me a [ __ ]
whatever Black Label Society CD that's
tremendous it was just a great time so I
want to thank you guys for coming out in
Florida is such a different [ __ ]
place
they had chickens walking around in the
[ __ ] all over the city I was smoking a
joint one time taking a little walk like
at 6:00 in the water right and there was
chickens [ __ ] [ __ ] cow all more
than she because it was still dark out
the first morning I got to do radio oh I
had to get a bit I got up at 5:00 like
an [ __ ] did I have no chicken near I
got just imagine you in like a city
chickens on the streets well this is
Ybor City okay very a lot of history
really you know the Pirates were there
like the pirate Pittsburgh Pirates
but like real pirates with Santo
Trafficante stone tamp it's a mafia time
you always hear about like how Texas is
or is its own country almost but like
Florida there's so many different areas
like each cities is different like
Orlando's kinda like Burbank essentially
it's like Disney and kind of seems cool
and then where my dad lives
like literally I'm surprised they have
schools but I don't see any children
it's like all 90 year old retirement
communities and then like you hear about
Miami which is college kids and like all
the pretty people Florida is really do
you ever do a lot of cuz you've done so
many gigs everywhere do you were you all
over Florida no no I'm only been to
Jacksonville to do comedy Tampa this is
the second time Miami really west palm
yeah that's that I'm not going on a
[ __ ] state that's a big-ass [ __ ]
state like Texas also Oh was funny last
night I called you you called me and for
the first time you watch this 60 minutes
yeah oh my god is about the opioid
epidemic and how the big farm and how
the DEA think I stopped prosecuting
cases and [ __ ] yeah you see that oh I
saw that it was amazing whether the
American watch is that that's patriotic
it really believes in the system like a
guy like yourself it kind of breaks you
in a way like me I'm used to it
yeah you know it's like when you watch
the first season of narcos well the
second season icons may explain what
happened in 85 I lived through that so
unless you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you really
don't know they were having a problem
getting ether into Columbia right plus
at that time I don't know if it was one
of the bushes declared war on Columbia
so by that time the narco
had pulled their cocaine them we're
developing in labs in Cuba
holy champagne Fidel 800,000 of shipload
for cocaine that they would ship into
the [ __ ] States but they were making
60 million a day right I give a [ __ ]
about a hundred thousand dollar payment
so the same thing happened
they got tougher on it because they
wanted in yeah if you remember in narcos
he goes maybe they want it or maybe they
just wanted a piece of the pie I mean
and this is we will get back to 60
minutes but I also have seen stories
that now Pablo's son is saying that his
dad was just wasn't working for the CIA
and the DEA is there's any part you
believe that's true I don't give a [ __ ]
okay he's dead what do I give a [ __ ] you
know if he says he was working for the
CIA listen in today's [ __ ] world you
never know when that world right when
there's that much money in Bob Lee
right that much money involved there's
always a by the way or you have to
assume there has to be I mean if you
remember narcos they said that they've
caught him on the tarmac of loading a
plane in Nicaragua right so they were
doing business with communists you know
who knows what the [ __ ] they were doing
and they caught Oliver North I mean when
it comes to the CIA and all those topics
it's a big question more well it's it's
sort of the same thing like how you were
talking about the DEA it's and you were
right it's I consider myself patriotic
I'm not I don't have a flag like I don't
consider myself an extra patriotic but I
have you grew up do you believe and you
believe in the system right exactly
even the systems either protect you and
you believe that the system is here to
make the best decisions that can for you
but in the long run you see something
like the 60-minute interview last night
both of them both of all the one guy
that became a lawyer is ship but that
was interesting you know 60 minutes I
didn't largeness as I was a kid because
you could sit there and give a [ __ ]
about all the news in the world or you
could just cut to the chase give me
three stories that are interesting to me
and I'll get two out of three of them to
write interesting that's why you always
DVR because you could speed through the
second one
I won that old [ __ ] is doing an
interview or something like that
but if such a it comes at you from a
different perspective and they do such a
professional job on it you see it leave
here LOD now about the logs there's a
lot more journalism out there than there
used to be but when you see 60 minutes
it like for me I don't know it just
seemed more professional than a lot of
the other news that you see nowadays and
to me I and you're right i I believe in
the government I book I want to it's not
even as much as I do it's that I really
I hope I wish that I could and to hear
that they're all all it boils down to
his money I mean I don't want there's no
problem right no no but how do you feel
about how does a guy like you feel about
some something like the Kennedy
assassination when you grow up with that
as you I mean hi I looked at it you know
I'm not here to judge no bond right I
don't know if he could shoot what the
[ __ ] do I know I was maybe three when it
happened but 10 months old I [ __ ]
don't know it was so it was so much
history like I don't even remember in
the 60s right 66 63 66 I don't [ __ ]
know but the thing is that you look at
something like that and they keep
telling you our government did it and
it's like the Catholics it's like with
me with Catholicism when I look at an
article that says enlarge Bishop got
transferred because he raped 70 kids
right in my heart I don't really want to
believe it but it's the truth
and it's the same thing with government
to some people like it was to me I also
believed in the government but growing
up in North Bergen I saw and such a
micro level level that I knew if this
was it at the micro level I can't
imagine what it is at the macro level
and it's like I was telling my wife when
when you're at the macro level you get
donations from corporations and
industries that sway your decision you
know which is what's a donation a legal
bribe right yes what a donation
basically is to a [ __ ] whatever it's
not like $500 I love you so much I'm
gonna give you a million dollars it's
because in a year from now I'm gonna try
to pass a [ __ ] thing
and you're gonna okay for that million
dollars I gave and not even okay it that
this is the part that I had just no idea
about like they were talking about
lobbyists and all that and they were
saying like the former one of the former
lawyers for the DEA who switched over
which is he wrote the [ __ ] new Marino
bill how do you write the bill how do
you write the [ __ ] bill for
legislator
I thought years had to do that person
yeah and then well he probably wrote it
got it passed you know a few things like
yeah I just gave it to the dude and then
a year later he was working for a big
pharma guy and they showed videos of
this guy
yeah not lobbying yeah he was well no
yeah that that was before because he was
a DL and then when he quit when he got a
fire a great no he made like an advert
hasn't been advertising from self saying
that if you have a company and the DEA
is up your ass he'll come and get him
out of your ass and that's what and then
and that he did the marino bail after he
was a happy da let me ask you this blank
did your girlfriend know she was at the
dart game you know it's pretty
interesting that you see out there there
on one side of the law right 15 [ __ ]
years giving it everything and one day
it all goes out the window it's just
like an actor it's just like De Niro
it's just like a fighter you believe the
system for so long and then one day you
go or give a [ __ ] just give me the
[ __ ] I'm come quitting this [ __ ] and
I'm gonna go make 10 times when I was
making here for less work for Less work
and I don't get shot at and I wear suits
like little expensive [ __ ] lunches
and people take me out to lunch you know
that's when you come out of the collage
school or any other thing you come out
so gung-ho you're gonna save the world
and of all this [ __ ] yeah and then you
see your cohorts driving [ __ ] you
know Maseratis and taking six weeks
vacation and you're still working for
the city prosecuting [ __ ] gangbangers
and [ __ ] on whatever right you gonna
do after a while same thing you've
already learned the loopholes of the
system now you're gonna go open up your
own attorney and [ __ ] in
and exploit those blue polish that's
what it basically is you're switching
governments and now you exploit those
new poles for a [ __ ] tremendous
salary better tremendous living you know
I tend I fight ten fights I'm hurt you
know what I know I'm [ __ ] stuttering
I know I'm here in Chinese people
yelling at night right yeah shower [ __ ]
it I'm gonna take ten more fights at
$250,000 a fight I don't care if I get
beat up as long as my family has a
couple million when I die what do I give
a [ __ ]
same thing happens to actors I'm 58 I
brought it into this [ __ ] acting
[ __ ] and one thing again me it got
me to Oscars like I beat by [ __ ] some
monkey one [ __ ] year that I hadn't
made it monkey you know what [ __ ] you
I'm doing every [ __ ] script there is I'm
calling it in and that's how I'm gonna
go out and a lot of people think that's
the narrows reasoning now I don't really
agree I just think that there's a bunch
of shitty movies coming out that's but
it like it's it's amazing what we do for
money and how it just all that's all
really boils down and it's there's
people out there who don't there's like
there are some people who just do it for
the love of it and it they almost get
made fun of it's almost like look at
this idiot who actually cares about
stuff I know me as a comedian I was
having a lot better time when I was
doing comedy for freaking now I'm
considered a professional right and
there's so many checked things on the
list uh-huh before I go onstage and it's
so sad how so many people that around my
life don't understand those checklist
you all understand that maybe like
friends of mine like a friend of mine
came up from Clearwater that I dated and
she said it she goes when we were
sitting at the end of the show she told
her boyfriend she goes you know it's
really weird to see that I still
remember seeing Joey and scene in
Colorado and now 20 years later he's the
[ __ ] heaven wanted and not just a help
she said it to me she goes I it's
amazing to really see but she goes out
so remember how you stuck to it she was
the reason we broke up is because you
stuck to this you know that was what you
wanted she gonna stay you didn't want to
go out at night you didn't want to do
anything this was it feel and she goes
it was great for two years but then
account really old that you were that
serious about it and it was a compliment
to me you know I was [ __ ] 38 the
summer I had nothing going on in my life
and she was a party girl so I read other
week she had a family member coming out
here she always had a friends in college
coming out here they stayed with us and
to top it off we have to entertain and
she would get mad at me like we're going
to Venice I have a good time I got a
show tonight I am NOT [ __ ] going to
Venice and one of the store that I have
there might be a fall and I can make 15
bucks or I could just get that much
better
she didn't [ __ ] understand
it's hard I think it's I don't think a
lot of people have something there that
passionate about well you have to be
that passionate and that driven to
really excel in your field and people
don't know that that's the dedication
level that you have to have to really
excel in your field whether you're an
attorney whether you're you know in any
level if I'm gonna turn and I keep
[ __ ] around and I keep making wrong
choices my first two or three years it
is Cassius Joey Coco Diaz what's going
on what's up buddy how are you I'm
fantastic Lee how you doing I thank you
guys so much for having me on tonight
hey buddy good day you know we like to
do I yield checkup with our little
brother [ __ ] cash is updating Canada
running things oh well thank you man
it's been it's been a lot of fun out
here I did the podcast over on you guys
event as we go in fantastic you the
Action Bronson episode was killer man
yeah we're trying man you know there has
a podcast of yourself you know that
there's up to there's valleys this peaks
and valleys and you have to capitalize
on the [ __ ] peaks and everyone
somewhere I gotta bump into a valley and
you keep plugging you stay consistent
your stay on top of social media just
like you do and everything work thanks
off out man I mean you're doing a
[ __ ] fantastic job over there well I
really appreciate that Joey I mean it's
you're right I mean when you're doing
the podcast it is always that a band
flow I find that the easy part is
initially peaking people's interests the
harder part is keeping it and that's
where the persistence that you just
mentioned comes in like you really got
to be working at this every day and if
you're not is simply not gonna work out
you got to put your all into it when you
just called in we were talking about
dedication Michael Knight I moved here
in 97 I had a girlfriend she was a
dancer you know she was a stripper and
she made money and she wanted to do
different things on the weekends and I'm
like that's not my game I didn't move to
LA to go camping on Saturday it's on
I don't give a [ __ ] what I what the
[ __ ] ocean looks like I needed here
to become a comic and eventually that
and a lot of other things broke us up
but she came to see me Saturday night
after the show that's what she said she
goes at one point she goes I still
remember you being coked out sending
envelopes up I can be up doing blow till
5:00 in the morning licking envelopes
for free [ __ ] movies and agents it
was it was non-stop but what people
don't understand she said it she goes I
didn't understand the debt now I would
tell everybody to attack things the way
you attack them and that's how you have
to arrive things and that's how you're a
tackle yeah I mean it's something that I
realized after you know when I was a
little younger like I took a hiatus from
podcasting in general and I just really
realized how much of a hit that is to
you and I also realized you know this
past year you know how much distractions
can do you in like you said you know
you've got to avoid those kinds of
situations and that and I mean it's
really really difficult but it again
it's all about that focus it's funny
because you call a distraction but most
people do Joey caches you your [ __ ]
party poopers there's a huge party
everybody's gonna be there Saturday you
know all our friends are gonna be there
what do you mean you have a podcast at
eight o'clock well a podcast at eight
o'clock you know or Def Leppard's coming
to town so can't you blow off Def
Leppard's and go see them in Ontario or
something else and you're like no
they're playing here you know I want to
interview the [ __ ] drummer with the
one arm and that's the only time I could
do it so [ __ ] you and your [ __ ] party
and people think you're antisocial or
people think that you're I don't know
what these are they're saying is like
like a party pooper or something but the
bottom line is if this is what you want
to do this is what you have to do this
is it yeah there's no [ __ ] thinking
about it there's no feeling sorry for
your girlfriend
when you have a girlfriend you have to
fill her in from the beginning right
that's the big mistake that a lot of
guys make in the beginning they hook up
with somebody like the [ __ ] and then
they like yeah I'll do this I'll do this
I'll do this and then cut three months
goes by you've already violated that
[ __ ] 80 times it's time for you to go
back out in the jungle and do comedy or
play music or interview rock stars like
you do and now you're a bad guy you've
changed no I never changed so if you dip
that [ __ ] in the bud from day one they
know exactly what time is whether you're
dating a girl or boy I don't [ __ ]
know anymore so I'm not talking about
you casually I just don't want people to
think that I was gonna say you know
what's up with me Joey yeah I know
you're a dick slinging a little dirty
bastard I see you had there kissing and
hugging [ __ ] I just want to get right to
it I mean for at least for me my
question
tell me about getting gene Simmons on
because that I just can't eat like I
remember I've seen pictures of you since
what I started with Joey that was six
years ago and I think you've been doing
podcasting for like seven or eight now
and you've always loved kiss so I can't
I just want to hear but that's what I
want to hear about it was an insane
thing Lea I mean like I showed up to the
expo I've been trying for I mean close
to I think it's eight or nine years now
to get the interview and I've been told
by like you know members of KISS they
said listen Gene's never gonna do this
man
like we understand that you really want
him on he's not going to do it and when
I came to the Expo I had a media pass to
the Expo that he was signing at and they
even told me gene is not doing an
interview and then finally somebody who
works for the band who shall remain
nameless of course actually gave me the
chance to send a formal email request
and have it sent to Gene's personal
inbox so he could decide so after you
know eight and a half some years finally
it came down to gene and he saw it and
he liked it and he personally responded
to the email he said he would be happy
to say hello and do the interview so I
called the Expo I said listen you guys
got you guys got something twisted right
now I'm doing this interview and they
said alright this Gene's choice and it
was it was one of the best days of my
life honest
he was it was really a dream come true
when I saw it I was so [ __ ] happy for
you and then I saw it on six you know
and on a Nikki Sixx's show and a lot of
people will retweet this [ __ ] I was like
oh my god this kid hit the [ __ ]
jackpot but this is because he's been at
it for eight of nine [ __ ] years most
people would have believed that and gave
it up yeah there's no easy way into it
they were boy your dream so his the real
right I mean it's literally why I
started when I was like nine and a half
some years old I I heard a podcast about
kiss and they ended up interviewing
members of the band and I said I want to
start and eventually interview gene
Simmons or paul stanley and that's why I
even started podcasting so after all
this time it feels insane but but the
thing about it is that as much as it is
great and it's a big accomplishment for
me I only view it as the beginning so
like now I kind of take the last nine
years and rip up the drawing board and
it's just time to restart I'm not trying
to you know be fine to a high off of it
you know what I mean
well I mean I I see what you're saying
but that at a certain point and I think
a lot of people who are creative have
this issue is they don't give themself
enough credit sometimes and so I like
obviously you can't just set them to
like all your interview gene Simmons
I'll never interview anyone else but
it's also I think it's important to
acknowledge what you've done I don't
know that's why I'm acknowledging and I
think it's at I think you've been on a
great run you know I've seen you
interview other people and this one was
the cherry now yeah you're right now
this is you're on to bigger and bigger
[ __ ] things you know right and I mean
like I'm certainly appreciative of every
single thing like I still interview
people that people haven't even heard of
at this point just because I'm a fan of
what they do and I want to help tell
their story so I mean it's not that I
don't appreciate it and I'm kind of
trying to gloss over it it's just that
you know again distractions I feel like
if I you know sit here and get fat
eating and thinking about the fact that
I interviewed gene Simmons is going to
distract me from interview in the next
and I'm but it it does feel good like
the past two years it's been hard man I
mean I've been banging on the door of
all these celebrities like I've been
going for Drake I've been going for Wiz
Khalifa big guys and for two years
straight I would just get a nose to
everybody at a certain point and it you
know it pays off to be persistent that's
why I would tell people really like if
you watch this morning's or yesterday's
periscope I said listen every [ __ ]
know you get leads - yes yeah I love
when I get those because every [ __ ]
no eventually you know it bump into a
[ __ ] yes mm-hmm so that's been
that's been my thing since I started
comedy I was like people gonna say no to
me you know what but I know the more
they say no vent y'all come closer to my
ass and brother I've lived it so I could
see now that you're living it it feels
good to be a gangsta yeah yeah who's
going up there next couple months you
think of them foot requesting for well
the next big one is coming up on October
24th and it is you're gonna love this
Robert waters oh [ __ ]
it was right who shows what did you
think so far what has he said so far I
haven't gotten a response yet I only
fired off one email but that was even
before gene Simmons came on so I think
now that that's happened if I can find
someone you know catch their to put in a
request that might happen because he's
been doing a lot of interviews this is a
legendary tour for me like with Trump in
office and everything and he's doing all
the political stuff I mean this is this
is gonna be a highlight of my youth so I
can't wait for this good what are you
doing for work now when I contacted you
last week you have a job though yeah I'm
working full time at least eight hours a
day so it's not too too bad it's at a
liquor store and it's it's pretty crazy
I mean I deal with the fest I deal with
a lot of that kind of stuff but it's
steady hours and you just got to be
careful watch yourself and why are you
still taking classes at all anything I'm
finished with the Nate stuff right now
that's what I was doing over here in
Edmonton it was like a six and a half
month program it was pretty intensive
just like I've learned how to work a
soundboard in a radio station and just
you know the mechanics behind the scenes
as well as new on-air techniques so it
was super super helpful and we I have
the option to go into like a two-year
full intensive course for it but I even
asked the instructor of the course and
you said he doesn't really think it's
necessary at this point no I think you
got most of the guys that are there now
I mean you're [ __ ] living right you
know there's that what you want to do
stuff with sound boards and well I want
to take it to a level where I can kind
of branch out and make income off a lot
of different things I want to be on some
kind of television or Sirius radio
station doing interviews also doing
comedy stuff funny bits I also want to
branch on my photography because I
photograph concerts a lot now as well
that's a really good way to make cash
you know just these kind of things I
want to to be able to branch out to you
know six or seven different things
that's really the plan have you
connected with Maurice your alvarado yet
I haven't I haven't heard that name
before he was on the podcast the last
time Dean Del Ray was on and young as he
is you hear I have responsive as much
respect for him as I have for you
because every month these guys started
zero and they're taking pictures and
they're selling pins so he went into the
pin business but he's almost pinned you
you stick on your jean jacket or on his
leather jacket and it says like Black
Sabbath mastery I'm just gonna say take
him back to the Sabbath days right so he
did all of them and he connected with
Sabbath now so he's working with Sabbath
on those pins and you know when I talk
to you when I see what you're doing and
I see what he's doing it's like too big
you guys are both on the same path he
takes [ __ ] phenomenal pictures
then he doesn't interview and he does a
block only and it's like the full
[ __ ] experience he's always I would
definitely have him on my show no
problem yeah no no but I think you guys
should connect on a business level okay
you guys could be [ __ ] international
and huge Wow
I mean that's how many coming from you
I'll do it no no no I think you guys are
on the same path I think you guys join
[ __ ] forces so he's young he's a
long-haired [ __ ] Mexican Cuban kid
who's out listen he's out six nights a
week I think tonight he was going to see
the pêche mode you know he's really out
there yeah he's out there he's out every
[ __ ] night press passes for he brings
me [ __ ] to the Comedy Store
I still got his Tony Iommi pictures from
the Hollywood Bowl he just saw me Judas
Priest did something that though whiskey
without glenn tipton and he sent me a
few pictures I mean he's just a dynamite
[ __ ] kid man but you and him together
oh it's like the [ __ ] Medellin Cartel
that beautiful man I'll definitely reach
out to him absolutely listening right
now man hit me up okay what's going on
with the girlfriend I don't have a
girlfriend at this time who was that
girl I saw you hugging up with playing
Harvey Weinstein with on [ __ ]
Facebook that was my girlfriend two
years I decided to end the relationship
about a month and a half ago you know I
don't you know I don't have too much
common I mean it's difficult to manage a
lot of things in your life especially
when you're pursuing a dream so that's
really that whole 0:19 actually on
November 5th where do you get your
clarity from
I mean these I don't know
I mean 19 and you're full of hormones
somebody's looking at nuts once a week
and you're eating that [ __ ] and out
of nowhere you decide to stop dating
them because you want to pursue you
career you're not only kids your age do
that I mean a long time to be fair all
right you know I kind of went off the
map for like three months okay because
you were loved or because big time okay
and there's nothing wrong with that for
a guy your age so once you fell in love
you said this is a little too deep
I still love Black Sabbath more kiss
more gene sevens more yeah yeah I mean
it's super deep with her and one of the
main things that I mean she was really
it wasn't even that she was dragging me
down to a big point to where it was
impossible to get any work done get any
episodes done needed that constant
attention and when I was flying to
Halifax for my vacation because while I
was on that vacation across the country
we ended up breaking up I listened to
you and Steve Simone and Lee and you did
the podcast we were talking about
sacrifices and that our conversation
pretty much changed my life at the time
it was like it really opened my eyes to
what needed to be done like it's not a
it's not a compromise and there's no
time for compromise so that's what
needed to be done you know I'm really
happy that you took that conversation
art I mean I'm sorry that you broke up
made you break up with your [ __ ] girl
fine ever like doing something like that
or it wasn't working anyway no I know
and I understand that but that word to
me means so much but to so many [ __ ]
people
they'd only ever in their life want to
go there and it scares me how a person
wouldn't want a sacrifice for what the
[ __ ] they love
yeah I mean it that you don't love it
that much clearly that's what that tells
me it's like you you I don't want to
love it or you feel like people think
you should love it but if you love it
there shouldn't even be any hesitation
at all you know it's uh I'm writing this
book I'm putting these chapters together
and I put the proposal together the
proposal is done Thank You Church family
for [ __ ] believing in me I'm gonna
send it to Gordon tomorrow Wednesday and
get the notes on how I'm no [ __ ]
Hemingway which I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
happy that I'd stuck to it and did it
for the first time in three years I
stuck to my [ __ ] commitment it took
me three years you know to take two and
a half months off three to four hours a
day correcting [ __ ] you know just to do
this but right now I'm just writing just
to continue $1,000 thousand words a day
and today I was writing something that I
don't think I should tell you guys but I
have to I had you know I was writing
about 1995 and how I had nothing in my
life except this little girl that was
five years old and comedy for the first
time in my life since the age of 16
something had [ __ ] worked and it was
calmly did I have high hopes of being
Bill burr or louis c.k I never thought
I'd make it that way
but I knew thousands of guys that never
went that way that was still making a
living on the road they weren't getting
real rich but that least they weren't
stealing or snorting coke but that's all
I wanted but when you started comedy did
you love it yeah oh you're just doing it
as like a job yeah what point did you
love it no I loved it the first time I
got on stage yeah like after I got off I
knew that was it I had been high on 20
different types of drugs and I had never
felt anything like that and I didn't
know well you know I didn't do well
Cassius I'm not gonna lie to you and
tell you I got a stand no no no no I was
talking about Godzilla and dinosaurs but
I knew there was something there I knew
that if if I stuck with it
but I could probably make a living and
sell CD's on the road and live in a car
like Charles Bronson I knew I would make
money at it but at one point I had
nothing in Boulder I mean when I tell
you I had nothing in Bogor I had nothing
I had a job I had a job if I wanted to
stay I could probably make about 60
grand a year but I didn't want to do
that job everybody I did that job ended
up [ __ ] up because it was a bad karma
job and I know it so all I had was that
little [ __ ] beautiful five-year-old
girl and stand-up comedy and I had to go
with the stand-up comedy because I was
just doing her wrong by being there we
were creating so much havoc but stand up
to me when I made that decision I knew I
was on to something but that was one of
the bigger that sacrifice cost me four
or five years of my life acquiring
myself to sleep every night but that was
what it would take to get to where I
want it to be and today I'm not where I
want to because I never thought I would
end up here anyway I just thought I
would just become a good comic and
travel Idaho and you know Montana and
[ __ ] those guys that do it that
you've never heard of yeah I know I know
they're the 10 times funnier than the
guys that are
they are the guys that you're exposed to
those guys that never leave Chicago that
would come out here and break those
clubs in half do you think they're
happier they somewhere along the line
they're locked up they're scared there's
a fear element maybe there's a better
one like getting out of their comfort
zone you know but that's one thing about
you man I saw you with Jean and I'm like
this [ __ ] guy is comfortable I mean
his microphone ain't shaking you know
his hand they say that it comes off that
way at least no yeah I mean the cash is
she ramen to something you're right or
something I mean you know you could you
know in a year you could pitch rolling
stone and say hey your magazine sucks
ass let's go [ __ ] digital and give me
the back page Division of concerts
pictures you're a one-man show right now
I don't know if you know that problem
well you brag about Harry the highest
word listen you put a Facebook group
page together and call it my concert
blog and more interviews on there you're
a hit bro you got some sponsors you're
good to go you quit your [ __ ] liquor
store job in a year you submit to that
yeah no that's that's the goal and it
means really a lot to me to hear that I
I really just want to take it to new
heights and I also just want to show
that you don't need a huge corporation
you don't need a huge studio you don't
need to be co-signed by big businesses
to get your word out there to get paid
from your home to be your own boss to be
you know the ringleader buying the show
I do have one collaborator his name's
Jesse Yan song and me and him are gonna
be hit in LA in December and doing some
work he's born and raised out there
you know what that be gonna come and see
us and do a bong hit with us finally it
would be an absolute honor I've been
training that he would call it I've been
training to meet you guys with the
resource oh we got to do that I'm so
[ __ ] excited listen Ben you've uh
you've made me a fan you know I'm a fan
of yours you've made me believe in the
system I'm happy that my beliefs are
still alive that there's still people
who don't give a [ __ ] yeah this is what
I want to do and I don't give a [ __ ] you
know what I'm gonna do I got 3,000 in
the bank
my rent is 750 a month that means I'm
good for 3 months and a couple [ __ ]
groceries I'm gonna start blogging
taking pictures I'm gonna put all the
concert tickets on a [ __ ] Visa card
and I'm gonna take a chance and I'm
gonna take a chance I got uh some gold
my mother got some bonds that my
grandmother left me and that's my
emergency fund I'm going for this and if
you really go for something like that
like what you're doing pictures a blog
boom and get a couple sponsors to your
page it's endless
like I said what how many people really
by Rolling Stone magazine is it online
Rolling Stone magazine I'm sure some
form of it is yeah you know I would yeah
they have a website with articles yeah I
would just attack them right now and
don't listen you like that [ __ ]
almost famous guy you know he's a he's
16 right you're like the almost famous
guy you're like whatever Camry well I
said that movies great at this point you
probably won't even need a job when you
move to LA but for something in LA
that's frustrating for me is or and just
for a lot of people in our end
industries you have to do everything
like so it's amazing that you already
are doing that with the pig-like when
you apply for jobs or you see job
postings out there now for even
entry-level PA jobs they want you to
know how to take pictures do graphic
design video editing audio and you have
to be a one-man crew are you serious
they want you to know graphic design
everything I mean for the ones I was
applying to and lucky there are some
that like
bring it on there to hope that you have
it but yeah they want you to know
everything they want you know all these
programs they want you to have a real
from a very young age so the fact that
you have gene Simmons on your real like
that that they just do 30 seconds of
that and pulses are you real some of the
bigger ones I've had was Eric singer of
kiss I had Tommy Chong recently I talked
to Carly Rae Jepsen and breast and peace
John Dunsworth I did two interviews with
him one of them was about three months
ago any past today but he was one of the
biggest ones from Trailer Park Boys rest
in peace John you're really out there
man one of the concerts are you looking
forward to seeing the comedy area one of
the biggest ones that I'm looking
forward to seeing is jay-z I mean I'd
never in a million years thought I would
see jay-z but they built a really crazy
state-of-the-art arena in Edmonton now
it's actually the number one arena in
North America so all of a sudden we're
just getting a flood of artists that we
never got to see before like we got tool
recently I saw them for the first time
life-changing yeah it's been really fun
out here Edmonton is really a good place
to be for what I'm doing and I try to
take full advantage of it I'd say what's
gonna be life-changing is Roger Waters
Tuesday night oh yeah I'm going with my
sister and possibly even my mother who
loved Roger Waters in the 10th grade and
it's just it's gonna be beautiful
oh we went and already called me that
night [ __ ] blown away and I had a
comment down like I had to explain to
him he couldn't understand and I told
them I had to go listen that's 40
[ __ ] years we're doing comedy 20
thankfull 40 [ __ ] years how sharp you
are right when the Dark Side of the Moon
come up I mean that's not that first
time do I think 75 right I think okay is
it 75 73 well is it oh sorry
tell us 73 Mark Lyons you're zealous
yeah 73 so before that I think it was
like they had like the first time is
Piper at the Gates of Dawn and then they
had a couple back for that the first
time I really
was with money was darkside the mold and
then I got in fact waited and I went and
bought over gamma by mistake but that
took me that was a little weird and I
don't have any record right then that
brought wish you were here and then
animals and then you know I was waiting
for [ __ ] the wall to come out like I
was right there so I think of the wall I
think of what he did to me with the wall
mm-hmm
and reality the wall made me don't want
to see anything ever again
yeah like that's how good when I saw it
in 1980 February of 1980 I was blown the
[ __ ] away yeah I did some [ __ ] double
barrel sunshine acid or whatever the
[ __ ] I was doing
that'll help I did a bunch of drugs for
that but he was they were phenomenal
they had taken me somewhere else then I
had never been before
and entertainment and I saw everybody
except Led Zeppelin and like deep purple
but I saw everybody from that 70s crew I
didn't see how John I don't think I
think I saw I mean John years later but
not that when he was throwing heat when
I was a kid Pink Floyd took me and
opened my head that night like it took
me three or four nights to get over it
and I can't imagine that was 1980 is
what 37 [ __ ] years ago
if he was that sharp back then what is
he gonna be like this time around it's
gonna be a next level type of show I
mean it's very public how much Trump
stuff is gonna be in this show and again
it just it speaks on the time that the
times that we're in and that's what I
love about Roger Waters I mean back in
70 72 73 they were pushing the
boundaries talking about politicians and
a negative light one it was frowned upon
and like you said 40 years he's still
doing that he's still pushing those
buttons and standing up for what he
believes in and he's touring across
America I mean this guy has the balls of
dr. Dre on a Tuesday you know so
his uh when you say that his concert
involves a lot of Trump stuff what's he
doing on that oh he's doing everything I
mean when he doing Pig saying you know
Sharad you are gonna Trump up on the
screens and he's got Trump on the pig
floating around the arena hilarious yeah
hilarious it's the real deal
hilarious see if Roger Waters is coming
to Los Angeles just oh yeah I think you
should really go because I was honestly
I was really hoping you'd go to Black
Sabbath and I think that you really
should out of respect for them yeah and
yourself I know you love that stuff
you know man
I was leery of concerts you know like I
said I saw everybody I think now the
price the prices they charge you the
park yeah I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] yeah
yeah I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] that I'm a
little car to Ali and it's gonna cost me
50 just a [ __ ] park you know like at
a UFC event or a Knickerbocker event or
my friends go to see the Mets of the
Yankees it's [ __ ] up there to park you
know and that all that [ __ ] takes away
after the stay in Vegas three weeks ago
I really got a look at the situation you
know I'm taking a go to a World Series
game for the Dodgers I'm taking a
bringing my daughter and then any
concerned citizen would have to think
well what's it gonna be like at the
World Series is there would be a [ __ ]
mass shooter or something like this and
a [ __ ] game now so this wing is in the
back of your mind you know I don't know
how bad it is up in Canada but you know
this this last Vegas thing really
it took me three days to get over it no
yeah no it's terrible and we felt the
effects of it here in Canada I know
after the thing in the UK with ariana
grande I went to the first concert in
Edmonton after that was the Chili
Peppers and security was so so tight you
know that was the night that like I kind
of guess I've made the wrong moves in
the photo fit and I basically got
attacked and thrown out of there like
everybody was really on edge but you
know we feel for everybody involved
Jesus Christ I can't imagine going to a
concert now and trying to [ __ ] relax
at least for me I'm not gonna hide
anybody at least for me I have concept
for me is to [ __ ] take to edibles and
smoke some dope but I'm not gonna drink
oh yeah I'm gonna pay [ __ ] attention
caches but aids to sit there and watch
the guitar player and feel the power
from the drums well I heard that that
that dude on stage when I heard that
[ __ ] machine gun going off I'd
[ __ ] everythings I attack and faint I
would never dream of getting hit at a
[ __ ] concert like that
yeah I've seen fistfights a concert I've
seen Stephen Tyler get punched in the
face in Jersey at the soda Factory
I've seen some fucked-up [ __ ] at
concerts I never heard a 60 people
getting shot man and I'm sorry if you
listening to this I still haven't gotten
over this man I still have no
international tragedy I let me tell you
something well that was on stage a
couple times this week
I actually caught myself looking at the
light by going is this some appointment
you know like this this stays in your
mind man when you're up on stage when
you're out in public whether you rent a
horse track you know so but I promise
you that if Roger Waters is coming to
town what's a date Lee you me he was
here in June unfortunately oh he'll do a
second half of the tour he likes his
[ __ ] paper if he comes I promise you
that I will try to go see him because I
want to go after Ari call me that
excited I felt like [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
again
absolutely yeah no I totally understand
though and you saw these guys in their
heyday back in the 70s so I understand
that there's probably not the same
urgency that I feel having never seen
any intuition of these bands but I feel
like if you went you probably uh thank
yourself you know what man but I think
you're gonna get a better version than I
got how [ __ ] scary is that that guy
that's thirty one seventy I will dizzy
7067 if I'm 54 he's got he's gotta have
me by 15 [ __ ] years
how old is Rome into 68 so he must be
must be older than gene Simmons Wow how
long was interview total with him it was
five and a half minutes just because he
seems so incredibly exhausted from his
big weekend and I was honored to even
just be be there I didn't want to push
it you know you better respect people's
time so it always freely no he totally
kibosh that and actually when he opened
the curtain to tell the people outside
the curtain to be quiet I thought he was
walking out because I asked him that
question now let me ask you this have
you ever read South Bay's freely I have
so many times too and you totally said
no have you he doesn't even answer me if
he said no to yeah we're lucky he's 74 I
would love to see him on you guys's show
oh my I think I would have a heart
attack just the laughter I would laugh
every time my hair is interviews I
[ __ ] laughed my ass off I think he's
the funniest person in the world to me
he's so real and he's so let loose
that's the way you have to be like to be
a really good comedian and since he
doesn't do it for a living and he's been
doing it being a crack-up all his life
he's so [ __ ] good at it now
ya know he's totally next-level he was
the true rock star of KISS he was the
only one who really was out there you
know eatin those Gorilla Biscuits the
bazookas and you know he was really out
there with the women and everything and
he he did a big you know the other
members of KISS had the music but they
didn't have that I told you that when I
lived in Baldwin when I went back to
Boulder to get my life together in 94 I
was working for a sports betting service
and I had a friend Sammy and I was tired
of Sammy Sammy was a pimp and [ __ ] yeah
like a 30 he was 30 and his girlfriend
was 50 but a family owned late nineties
restaurants somewhere in the [ __ ]
country so he was one of that whole
driving a portion [ __ ] but him and her
had and she's dead god rest her soul
she's one of the sweetest women I've
ever met in my life when I was dead
broke cash as they would call me at the
house and go we're going on a date to a
movie theater we left the door open come
over and we made you [ __ ] Chinese
food watch your favorite movie and way
for us
it was mind-boggling and one night they
just happened to rip out you know I
don't know how many pictures of them
with Ace Frehley in Connecticut only
alright and I mean yeah I mean you had
to see that he was probably like uh
either you know my ace frehley was born
a ton of drugs and he would just talk to
anybody
he ended up hanging out with Sammy for
about two or three years and they became
right and Sammy never took a picture of
it cuz he was embarrassed but he said he
was in the car many a time and if you
opened up the glove compartment he would
have a slide-out mirror in there
nobody's ever done that I've never heard
of anybody doing that why would Sammy
make that up you know I didn't see it
but why would Sam II make that up I mean
he had pictures of him at a table with
beers everywhere and from the mirrors
doing coke with Sammy I mean you know
Sammy was a heavy dude and Ace Frehley
was and I heard that ace was just crazy
and that's how I got into ace like I
said I listened to kiss when I was 12
and 11 but my buddy died and I promised
him I would never listen to kiss again
until I saw him again in heaven but I
cheated recently or not yeah I cheated
recently I put rock and roll alone
what's that one
rock and roll over maybe yeah oh my god
oh yeah I want you and all that [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] yeah and kiss alive which
the last couple days of today was the
40th anniversary which makes it around
right I was 14 so yeah kiss a lot yeah
yeah
you need to check out Ace Frehley 1978
solo album just sit back give yourself
an hour and be blown away what's the
name of the out it's just called ace
frehley the back in this in 78 day oh
I'm sure you remember they were all
released their own kiss solo albums on
the same day so all four originals
competed and ace by a landslide was the
craziest album you had like psychedelic
Jimi Hendrix type stuff really won't
disappoint okay no no I'm a fan of his
so so what's next
Robin no I know you went dog listen I am
a huge fan of yours I have the utmost
respect for you you know even now
tonight after you told me that you
dumped a girlfriend nobody who was 19
dumps a little monkey a lot how old
piece ass for [ __ ] some [ __ ] [ __ ]
podcast career but you did it brother
have you remained friends no no there's
no need for that o blooded Cassius
Morris Jesus Christ
I mean you want to be at the top or not
no listen this is why totally all the
time Lee thinks I'm [ __ ] around here
thank God you came on the show he thinks
I play games and I make these mind
things up that there's a point in your
life where you really have to do
inventory for me no I mean you're doing
it in nineteen which I mean my heart
goes out to you you're a [ __ ] Savage
I didn't do anything like that so I got
into comedy but then it's weird you
start there's people you push away just
because you know then you can't even get
close to why would I even instigate this
I'm gonna rain fifty dollars over things
so she could buy a bracelet and I'm just
blitt you know saying at why that then
you get this power you really get this
power once you fall in love with what
you're doing that you start saying no to
a lot of things yeah and that's when you
go to a complete different level in your
life in your career once you start
sacrificing the things you love I really
love football
but if I can make 250 on a [ __ ]
and Sunday and get the education I want
to go where I need to go this is what
I'm gonna do and when you do like three
or four of them lets you once you show
yourself you could go without that's one
of the strongest things that you'll have
a feel in your life like when I went to
prison when I went to prison bro I
thought how was it to kill myself after
two days with no marijuana but the truth
was after a week yeah I had insomnia and
yeah I had some type of withdrawal and
you know but let me tell you something I
lived and my body learned how to sleep
without marijuana and I did just [ __ ]
thought what I do it today no there's no
need it's funny there's no need I spoke
to Duncan today he's flying in next week
and I go you're gonna see anybody goes
[ __ ] no I'm staying away from those
sober [ __ ] I died of [ __ ] laughter
he was I've been getting high all month
because I've been getting high all month
kashish man I gotta tell you something
I'm really proud I'm a fan and keep
doing what you're doing
thank you so much we have a life for how
long you'll be down here I'm hoping to
go down there for a week and we're
hoping to just cram in a ton of work a
ton a promotion for the cassius morris
show getting the iTunes page pop and
YouTube page popping and just keeping
our goals at the number one being the
number one focus and thank you guys
again for having me on ly I Love You Man
oh you have to go hold on so you'll be
here for a week okay do it where you say
that I'm not sure yet we haven't even
got to booking yet we're just starting
to plan the trip and plan the spots
would we want to hit right now okay well
listen this is one of the spots I liked
it all you can't even go to the comedy
store I can't what about the ice house
it didn't didn't didn't wasn't there
something that someone had to do like
have security bring them in to do the
spots or something maybe we could get
like a movie maybe yeah but cash was
doing a spot
I'll cast you Josh was to come I was
thinking about the underground podcast
studio where is that in duck in the
store
that might work we might get you down
there daytime I could talk down a little
absolutely brother I'll be great
anything I could do to help you like I
said you get a lot of my respect your
you're a [ __ ] giant a month amongst
kids your age and amongst people a lot
older them yeah yeah Wow so whatever we
could do for you here at the church you
got it brother
happy Halloween in fact thank you so
much uncle Joey the fact that you guys
have been there since day one really
means a lot like you were the first
episode of my non-kiss podcast and you
believed in me from day one
so that will always be in the world's
matrix that's me do you know I don't
[ __ ] around brother I see hard well I
know hard when I see it so thank you for
calling it and keep doing what you're
doing
absolutely and I hope everybody checks
out the cashes Morris show and we have a
new episode coming out tonight with
comedian drew Bane's so check it out
people so I'm talking about always
promoting on the way out this kids a
savage that's why I love them with some
Tony Bennett kid
absolutely much love you guys think I
just have buddies bye-bye bye-bye
you
- shoutouts real quick - you [ __ ]
savages lon Rosen come on Maine Jason
Sullivan Dave Delmonte my man Gino who
gave me the CD
Lorenzo Toledo you know I love your
brother I'm sorry I didn't see you down
it scott carpenter [ __ ] paranoid
album the Weber game of the album thank
you my girl forgot his bet my man Leon
listen my brother Bobby Sharon and
crystal have a podcast what's it called
now [ __ ] overcast kobracast except for
an award he's up for award if you live
in the Texas area Austin do me a favor
look him up and what was going on right
oh look the [ __ ] you breakin my [ __ ] for
you I forget look up Bobby Sharon's
podcast kobracast and vote for it he's
family he does a great job with the
[ __ ] podcast and he's one of the
sweetest guys I know and crystal [ __ ]
dynamite - so do me a favor give her the
Texas area to get to live in Austin if
you live in Austin go over there and
help my brother out number two I'll see
you [ __ ] in January number
three and number three Danny Brown is
down there
and he said that when we go down there
now we got a Chinese joint together
oh [ __ ] it's a rapper guy that we're not
gonna cook Chinese food and he goes with
a chance but it's damn close and they
got egg rolls and everything so we go to
Austin in January you're gonna get your
dream to eat some good Chinese food lost
and so excited it's like a Chinese
rapper huh I don't [ __ ] hot and
that's particular so don't forget
Thursday night comedy on Broadway
Lexington Kentucky Louisville all you
[ __ ] in Kentucky but do good
I'll be seeing you [ __ ] down
there don't forget about me I'm excited
to go back to Lexington number two what
was gonna say to you guys that was I
almost had a heart attack talking that
I'm [ __ ] yonke Cassius Morris he's a
great kid well I would never think of
dumping some chick from my [ __ ]
career in 19th when we're 19 I know I
know men today I know 50-year old men
but I've no [ __ ] control you know
that they don't see like they can't
weigh the balance
Queens what's the important thing in
your life and how to get the most out of
both and this 19 year old kid it's
rivalled listen man and we once in a
while you bump into people that uh let
you know your beliefs is still alive I
went to Tampa
and I became faster dude
where's the best Cuban sandwich he told
me El Duque whatever restaurant El
Segundo restaurant and I go you chew and
we start talking baby was talking me in
English like a hole in your Bennion cuz
I just got here in January I couldn't
you know English it was yeah I [ __ ] it
into the class and I needed that class
and then I study at home and I had
learned talking through people here I go
how'd you get this job because I got
this job he was the head he goes I
started as a maintenance man then they
can top on me quit so now I run the
department nine [ __ ] six months he's
been there nine months he's been in the
country six months he's had a job day he
bought a car he got a driver's license
he's got some type of apartment only him
and his wife came he was remedy kids
when I hear [ __ ] like that that somebody
did that my [ __ ] head blows up you
see what his Spanish he wasn't no
[ __ ] you no no no no stand-up comic
but I understood what he was saying and
he had a little paper with him just in
case he got stuck and he wanted to say a
word yelling a little [ __ ] big solid
sheet sheet or something like a little
cheat sheet so that was pretty
impressive to see Manish like I I saw
some homeless people the other day or
the other night and I just started
thinking like I don't know if I have the
strength to be homeless
so and in other situations like hey guys
welcome in the boneless obviously you
got no [ __ ] strength
well that's number one number two being
homeless there's various reasons that's
true and you like there's a guy that
lives on the bridge on Magnolia that
right he's been there for [ __ ] 90
days
you know when you stop that you could
tell he's on meth like he probably
losing the bushes at night but I've seen
a mother bridge when we finish the
podcast in time and I go for a drive
down a 7 1 listen you know there's
various [ __ ] trees right and mental
health is definitely one of the issues
and I don't look down I see I see them
as stronger than me because I just
entice people from Cuba like if I had to
go somewhere I didn't speak the language
I've always been terrible at speaking
languages I don't it's something that I
think I would avoid for that reason but
in that code that guy you meant probably
came here for a hopefully better life
yeah no that's it's a dream right it's
like Cassius Morris it's like whatever
listen you can't imagine bein homeless
no - yo listen listen you don't know
what it's like when you're in a bar till
3:00 and you're dreadin so ready because
you gotta find the place to go
I did that leave for about five weeks
toll you know I did it for like seven or
eight days then I got a place to stay
for a while I would have a hotel room
and then there was like [ __ ] I don't
know how many days in a row but I went
to that [ __ ] thing and then I would
take a night off and go to a hotel and
warm up for a night and then get another
42 long hauls to stay an extra night but
I'd be back in that [ __ ] rocket ship
and let me taste him there's not a night
you know why I like it called it a night
why to remind me I would have felt like
those nights and I slept out like to
remind me what they [ __ ] felt like is
it even possible for you to forget I
don't think no I never forgot that it
was the sexual abuse that wasn't mental
abuse I wasn't loving yourself inflicted
addiction abuse when your addiction it's
so bad that you don't care about your
[ __ ] sleeping habits alright yeah
your sleeping arrangements sorry about
that that's what it was you know how sad
that is
I [ __ ] wouldn't i6i levels because I
rather put it on my nose
wait so with that first night or
whatever and that maybe not even that
first night whenever I hit you that you
were homeless what was that like you
don't want to think about it you don't
think about it you just
play along and a fantasy becomes again
and just like I wanted to be a comic and
Cassius you have this fantasy that you
got a bump in the hallways and get like
a [ __ ] apartment Sunday so that's
what keeps you alive you know you go WOW
next week it's gonna be warm you know if
that's how I look that it's gonna be
warm I was will spend it on blow well I
think about that time it makes me want
to [ __ ] puke but I learned a lot
sleeping on that tear on that metal and
learned a lot about myself you know come
on man half those nights I would cry
myself to sleep but then I picked myself
up but I'd finish my coke and I jerk off
again and I'd pass out and wake up the
next morning and then I'd promised
myself that was the last time I was
asleep in that rocket ship but by a four
o'clock you know I know I was asleep in
a rocket ship and least somebody would
say to me way you but it's sleeping it
and I got a friend's house or something
you know but you just stay here that's
the only way I will gave it but after a
while I didn't want to stay with people
over because I was just gonna [ __ ] up
our friendship it was easier for me to
stay at that rocket ship and just stop
by your house when your parents ain't
home brush my teeth wash my face comb my
hair maybe jump and get a hot shower and
there was a lot easier for me that then
staying with somebody like that's how
bad it got like I was just cause havoc
and gaps were you were you even enjoying
cocaine at this point I was enjoying it
a lot so it's even fun even when you're
homeless it makes that fun what listen I
was homeless for 10 hours of my day
so for 49 we'll stop with that [ __ ]
bottle already but it's like I'm sorry
so for 14 hour you the producer you know
I didn't I didn't mean that's nothing
telling me that it [ __ ] with that
crappy bottle these bottles blow to this
we got together I got a different kind
this time well say thank you forget
savage it was I just didn't know I still
remember the feeling of that metal with
the ridges on it every at the scene when
you go on a kids playground how the
metal stuff has ridges that even the
rubber stuff now has ridges on every
time I look at those ridges I get
flashbacks of those nights when I go
home like that and I put my sleep apnea
mask on and the fans blown and it's cold
in there already
I like covering my head for 5 seconds
that feeling comes back and my body goes
food like you check to make sure you had
here in the house I had like a [ __ ]
hooded sweatshirt with like a winter
jacket with gloves and that's how I
would sleep I would clean the spot off
with my jeans and my shoe I would take
my sock off and clean it my feet would
be drenched and stinky from having the
same shoes on all day so I take my shoes
off and socks to give him there I'd
[ __ ] wake up in the middle of night
my feet would be icicles because number
I slept out there like a little bit
after Halloween then I got my act
together but till I went back out there
the two weeks after like I I started
sleeping like two days before Christmas
I finally got a place I said you know
what I cannot spend Christmas in the
[ __ ] rocket ship
for people who don't live on the East
Coast it was probably 19 in the in the
single digits when you were sleeping
outside in December you know till this
day I don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about were for us but but that
yeah I know it a some that yeah I'm
going on why he was a mom with huh it
was a mild winter and it picked up I get
picked up after I got in the hotel thank
God you know the the holidays are
usually mild in these coasts you get a
couple of winter spurts before that I
could see in the Yankee game tonight
they're ready and winter jackets on but
there's that little warm spurt you know
when you'll call me from Boston and God
set in degrees and it really is but
right after Christmas it just drops into
January and that's when I wasn't in a
rocketship I'm not gonna lie to you
about that I think wasn't that was what
it was brutal or not I left North Bergen
I went to bed at maybe for Lee you know
maybe for in a hotel room and when I
woke up late there was a foot of [ __ ]
snow on the ground and I had to walk the
path mark with my sneakers and I was
sick and come back and then had to lose
the drug dealer you have no [ __ ] idea
and a that mr. T came who I did not call
when I was in [ __ ] Tampa this weekend
because you know what mr. t was a Sarah
stolen my teacher who saved my life he
it's an hour away so that means he what
I had a drive in Howard took me watch
the show and then drove an hour back I
should have just got him a hotel room I
didn't think about his I was on the
[ __ ] plane home that dude saved my
life
On January 1st 1985 he got me out of the
rocket ship I'll end up staying with him
in this fan
now his two kids one of them is a honcho
for CBS Arthur so every time he comes
into town I meet him by Warner Brothers
and we gonna lunch you shouldn't talk
about his father that's what you will is
the one that yeah Nick our weather and
from the comedy storm we're talking
about my teacher we would didn't blow
with this [ __ ] probably that was Nick
that was also yeah that that was you
know I wouldn't I wouldn't say I was
poor the [ __ ] knows when my head was
that way when I'm asleep in that rocket
ship I haven't been up there one night
and having like three grams of coke and
having like a party up there for the
morning by myself and people would drive
by like in those days if you were if you
got a bag of coke and you had a bar
before you went home if you lived uptown
you drove down 88th Street Park because
you know people were out there gonna be
parked there like there was a couple
spots in North Bergen at that time there
was the coal factory that's a smartie in
the park yeah we drink at a bar till
3:00
all right you [ __ ] coke at a bar till
3:00 and then you go to a part 88th
Street Park 67th Street there was the
coal factory or 64th Street field and I
would park behind you when I get in the
car with you and we'd have a mirror out
and we get beers and we just drink me as
a small coke in the car and then they
invite 20 minutes somebody has to get up
to pee you know that's a [ __ ]
nightmare so you're out there freezin
yeah dog we used to smoke outside in
cars jeez but the famous spot was the
coal factory on 67th and carnage Avenue
if you go back there today I guarantee
your fine coat came back that I left
after than 30 [ __ ] years ago
somewhere and there was an upper lot and
a low a lot okay so it was a coal
factory that's been there forever in
fact one of those houses across the
street is where the Iceman lived right
1960 [ __ ] 6 that's where he was first
married that's where he [ __ ] lived on
that Street 67th in college
looking up [ __ ] we don't believe
me but that that was the main cocaine
spot okay cold factory when somebody
said where am i meeting you at 3:30
moving over the coal factory and there
was a lower level and there was a higher
level and if I described this team Lee
he would not believe it there would be
five cars parked back there park
decently and everybody in those cars
doing cocaine if the weather was warm
you get out outside and drink beer and
one of the cars had a mirror in the
trunk with coke and the [ __ ] mirror
where are the cops the cops would drive
by every what's an al but as long as we
weren't making noise and nobody was
still anything we knew the cops it
wasn't how it is now that they pull it
on yeah nothing like that jeez I still
gonna be none [ __ ] this face to be an
A&P parking lot I'm like 80 something
and burger liked them when I just
graduated I dropped out of high school
but the e I was supposed to graduate
me and the guys I graduated with or
getting high one two ends at an A&P
parking lot with the coke mirror on top
of the hood of the car right out in the
open like nothing what time of the day
11:30 at night which was the burning
like that was the main [ __ ] Street in
North Bergen I'm lying to you no no no
no no it was late I'll tell you why I
remember because we were parked in the
parking lot and I mean we weren't parked
in the spot we were parked where
somebody would drive like 'we didn't
give a [ __ ]
all right winning they would shut the
lights out behind Pathmark
annalisa unless you really looked in
there you couldn't really see anybody
unless there was 20 cars if that was one
car and four people standing outside
would be as they wouldn't pull over but
if there was like 20 people in five cars
they pull up if you stop at a MP parking
lot all right see you in like a couple
cars right so this night it was just
four of us with one car with the mirror
on top of the hood of the [ __ ] car
and we're doing cocaine outside and
we're giggling we're having a nice time
and we see this guy walking like with no
shirt on or some [ __ ] I don't forget I
don't I don't remember all the
particulars and by that time we used to
[ __ ] with people right we used to call
him all over and talk to him and tell
him how you're with this guy the guy
would know what you were talking about
is [ __ ] so we go over there and we start
talking to the guy and one of my friends
telling Ellison do you mind if we suck
your dick I think I don't know what to
do this poor bastard the sky was half a
memo as there was and now we give him a
beer we make him feel at home and my
friend says listen what do you think
and then we go suck a dick and this guy
starts panicking his [ __ ] he runs he
runs down the street the beer falls out
of his hand and the next thing you know
he he [ __ ] waves down a cop car right
there as he's running out of the parking
lot a cop car season he's like hello
hello those kids over there they want to
suck my dick and [ __ ] so oh [ __ ] the so
my friend pally Raja was his car so he
jumped in the car and started him put
the car in reverse in the mirror
I slid off the parking lot yes please
off the hood the rarest little off the
hood yeah as the glad wasn't the mirror
it was a an inch piece of glass
we had robbed his house and it was a
[ __ ] designer his house no no we had
robbed our house a guy can't got headed
there you know you have a bed stand
right these were the to bed stands but
they were locked so in those days if I
came in the house or something was
locked and I don't have the right tools
I took it to go so we took both bed
stands well you see there's a nightstand
nightstand like the ones us and sitting
next to your bed you just took it picked
it up went downstairs god damn it
but the beauty of it was that they had a
piece of glass on it that was about an
inch thick and about 18 inches across
each way it was just a square you know
right and I said [ __ ] I'll take the
whole thing and I took both [ __ ] but
that I used to take everything in those
days we know I didn't go I didn't
[ __ ] know like I didn't know so let's
say I go into the house and there's a
safe right like after like 1982 right
before with the Colorado the first time
ever I met this dude North Bergen I met
him to a friend the DiLorenzo the
Lorenzo's there was Kurt Chrissy fish
and [ __ ] bonehead good this is one of
the stories about it okay
so boneheads family knew this guy so I
became friends with him and we were
talking he's the one that used to give
me jobs the case joints out like
warehouses he taught me a couple things
like oh so it's a safe way you know if
you can't break into the safe right what
are you doing he goes we take it to go
and then we figure it out he goes
there's a guy over the city of attempt
to set he'll crack you say he's like a
guy in development so you might take a
while maybe 810 hours but there's
another guy that wants 25% I helped
break it down he's safe for four hours
feet so all you need to do is take the
safe to go and know figure it out once
you get it home but you can't bring it
home too sometimes they have those
detectors on minimus I beep see I think
it's the White House the guys gotta be
waiting you got a bust and open and then
dump the [ __ ] safe so much planning
goes into it I guess
so I spotted taking [ __ ] anything I
couldn't get into if you walked it there
must have been something in there Valley
that was my [ __ ] philosophy god damn
it will you cut so you think you think
you're protect a sell all this stuff
protect yourself I go into your house
and you have a little pin okay like a
little tin box like a four-hour fishing
box and it's got the combination on it
and you've got cash in there maybe some
blow you know any of those things I took
when I was robbing falling on you and I
could not believe how people really
thought that somebody wouldn't figure it
out that they'd just take the box all
you got to do with those things yeah
just get a screwdriver and just [ __ ]
stick one and on one end and one on the
other end and just go in the wrong
opposite direction and those things
would bust [ __ ] open when your heart
beatin then you want that cocaine I
would be like I didn't have the strength
of [ __ ] ten hopes I would stick to
fucking's
steady screwdrivers the sick ones and
just pull the opposite direction and
those boxes pop right open and you just
let me know where everything is I'm
gonna take the whole box to go so if you
got a house and you got one of those
boxes do me a favor for put 400 and then
leave it at that and leave it open so
when the kid does coming out so they get
to 400 that's all he thinks he gots
because that's just secret compartment
you got another place hitting inside the
closet behind two suits and the wall
that's where you have your 9,500 in case
there's an earthquake in case you got to
make a move that's where you got your
birth certificate that's where you have
the other thing you know that's how you
a bullet pray if you're a code dealer if
Lee knows I sell [ __ ] ounces and I
know Lee's a thief I'm always going to
leave an 8-ball out so the guy comes in
in a rush he finds an 8-ball he goes I'd
rather you take an 8-ball then you take
four ounces from me I would come in to
people's houses and they have all the
coke together like an [ __ ] that they
want sometimes they got hip and they
separate the pure [ __ ] from the cut [ __ ]
but I'd find I wouldn't even do that and
leave two piles I've cut [ __ ] out for
them one with a little rock and you
always leave 200 for the months because
you got to assume the guy who was
breaking into your house is an amateur
and he's racing against the clock
it's so if I see Li golf and I see that
he pulls into Subway sandwich I run up
to your house kick the [ __ ] door down
running to your bedroom open up your
drawers open up your bureaus I'm gonna
find something in your bureaus I'm gonna
find something in your little [ __ ]
[ __ ] bedstand you're gonna have
something hidden in one closet and some
hitting on the other you're always gonna
have little bites for them so they think
they want but your big bites are really
really hidden good and did you only
learn this or come up with us because
all your experiences I learned this from
being a thief right I thought it was the
dumbest things were people if you have a
safe and it's locked it tells me you
have something [ __ ] I'm taking the
[ __ ] said I don't have anything in my
house but if I could take the thing I'll
take the thing to go now
it's very difficult it's easier said
than done where they parked the car when
I came up here I didn't know there was a
safe home Lee's house it was in the
second floor
I got a walk down the cellar stairs or
gone elevator
he said Subway sandwich well if he pulls
up as I'm walking out of his house with
his [ __ ] safe
she always racing against the clock so
if you're an amateur well you're a
junkie like I was and I have a
drug-dealing you break into my house I'm
gonna leave little things for you so you
think you want if I'm a 4-ounce every
couple day [ __ ] dealer and I do a
little bit of blood two nights a week
and I [ __ ] go to New York City I come
from I've let say I live in North Bergen
and I go over the bridge to New York
City and my sister lives with me so she
watches but I'm this like she went
shopping you have that time window to
break into my house
you're gonna go in there how fast if I
tell you I'm leaving for a weekend or
I'm dead you're gonna find my look
because only an idiot wouldn't you've
got the whole weekend
please in San Diego he told her friend
of mine he was a San Diego let's bust
into his house
what are you go to bar it's on like
scouting missions no you'd put somebody
to follow him and then you'd call him at
the bar or something and make sure he
was there or he called you at a payphone
and then I would put you at a pay phone
across the street from the place I was
robbed so when I kicked through the door
the first thing I would do is spot you
okay I'd be watching you
so every every two things I do every
bedroom I go into the bedroom I get
something I come out and I watch you if
you're still clear I go into a closet if
you're still clear I go into a bedroom
bathroom if I come out and you're waving
your hands that means get the [ __ ] out
of that so the more time you give me if
I have a spotter the more time I have in
your room in two minute intervals so in
two minute intervals I could look at
your room and I can know the side of
your activity how often you have a spire
if I rob five things maybe twice if it
was a five if I thought that there was
only people money in there like a kilo
of coke or something and then I never
got nothing like that it was all my
imagination they would have a few ounces
a six grand eighteen hundred cash
and know it was there all for drugs it
was easy money way easy money
leah was easy money I found you take
when I lived in Bolton Snowmass Village
with Jimmy Buerkle okay you know I was
bored and I watched drug dealers
patterns and I was raised with drug
mills
okay and I know good drug dealers
a brilliant [ __ ] people how they
their job is not to be obvious right and
their job is to deter you so even if you
get to you're not getting this [ __ ] okay
so number one the drug dealers I grew up
with always move their mother or their
wife's mother in that
that means there's always somebody that
she may leave on Thursdays to go
shopping but those days you purposely
stable did she know she's security or no
she has no [ __ ] clue that she wasn't
even there
she has no clue why she's there and
you're given the 300 a week to stay and
you know groceries yes yes pay for a
bingo is [ __ ] at night so you get around
a bingo at night that's when you do your
drug dealing and now people know your
grandmother's Daryl like they're gonna
try to bust into your house that's
number one number two you don't put the
drug laying out the drugs never yes I go
to you I pay your rent but I come over
once a week I weigh my [ __ ] how boy you
told me Paul was not old I come over I
tore your little envelope I take my coat
collar you spread battle Paul knows
nothing how long did that last for like
a are you worried about neighbors seeing
you too much not really I'll switch it
up I'll have you with two other people
gotcha you know you get a skinny girl
that's hooked on coke a grandma wheat
you go with a bang her and stash your
[ __ ] the safe over there that she can't
get a filthy paws she tries all week
yeah they'll try all week you just get a
girlfriend and stash your coke at her
house there's so many [ __ ] ways you
know when you're dealing in that level
first of all you don't want the drugs in
your house so you don't have access to
if you come home at night from the bar
you don't want to have to out see how so
you bring some [ __ ] blonde chick home
you want to make sure for you to get
that Coke that has to be a struggle you
got to wake somebody up
you got a bearish yourself you don't say
it so you're pulling somebody who you
know I can't knock on Paula's door
creating the mortified I know I can't
wake me up at 3:00 in the morning
beside that leaves one of my part of
this so I don't want them to know I do
coke anyway that's why I give them the
cocaine that but once Pauly's I go over
that eight in the morning I pick up my
[ __ ] Lee makes me breakfast
we [ __ ] we talk about activities for
the day and then that night I drop it
off forget it as a [ __ ] milk box he
pulls her inside his house well
something like that you know I'm just
telling you like right you you haven't
even mentioned the police yet all right
like as any of this worrying you I'm
worried before you right now why because
I don't want anyone jails do like the
the ultimen whatever go what it makes
you not want to do it I don't know what
good service deterrent yeah it's what
I'm talking about deterrent what jail
would be a deterrent to me to do I mean
obviously everyone wants to make quick
money but no I think that's the reason
everyone almost people probably don't
sell drugs if sit like you like in it
like in like even a mole like that's
really the reason like some people
probably hate drugs so that's part of it
but if you knew you weren't gonna go to
jail for some road drugs to sell drugs
is the easy way out we all know that
well I did it I don't even make money I
was such a [ __ ] loser so I decided to
be a bottom-feeder and Rob drug dealers
you know that that's all it was I
learned how to do all that [ __ ] you look
at movement you look at a lot of [ __ ]
Tanner's but am i proud of it no but
that's who I was then
and made me who I am today can't you
back and cry [ __ ] it
they probably learned a lot of lessons
but now I know how to deter your house
and [ __ ] burglaries yeah so you have
like hittin compartments am I gonna ask
you where they are but no I don't have
nothin in my house without my wife and
kid over there I got the Rings that I
got no okay that's it but you're not
worried about people breaking in oh you
always have to be worried that's why I
got the cameras and the [ __ ] the
thing with the [ __ ] ring in front
that you could read that ring is [ __ ]
tremendous yeah it's very cool that ring
adds a whole new thing towards home the
guy next door Robin and his wife right
we're talking to my wife they said if
Terry bought the things that our
son-in-law would install it a very
natural he came over about a week ago
when I was there and he was there for a
couple hours I got a pie we cook some
gumbo for Michos and jambalaya and even
when I'm on the road I gotta install the
app but now you have cameras all around
the place yeah
now you this is the future this is it
you have to know you know and then you
know what the main thing is people
stealing your boxes yeah my wife [ __ ]
lives off Amazon
you know I'm home if I'm home for hours
in the day time and that doorbell rings
twice Bing bong
and then you go on there's nobody there
and you look down there's a box that
happens twice a [ __ ] day in my house
it's all the time yeah it's all I get we
got toilet paper delivered I had that
issue with my phone a couple we've been
there a year and they've knocked on the
door three times already asking us if we
saw a car at one o'clock Jesus so I just
said wait a second I saw the commercial
for ring and I saw the improvement they
made listen man it's not a it could save
your life
I'm not it's not it's not better than
the [ __ ] gun right but listen when I
pull up in my house you think I'm a
[ __ ] convict lights pop on from
everywhere it's crazy
my dad loved those lights yeah the
lights pop on from everywhere so listen
we live in different times the house
came with alone then we upgraded it with
the whole [ __ ] thing you know you
have to be careful now you have to think
about it you laughter so it's a
different world it's a different [ __ ]
world and that's how it goes
don't forget this weekend Lexington
Kentucky Thursday 8 o'clock now 7:15
show this is early I get you
[ __ ] out of there early in the
weekend there's like 7:15 and 9 or
something you're dreamin yeah on my
dream when I get back early on Sunday
more that's gonna be a [ __ ] party
Jack we got a great week we got a great
couple weeks Danny Brown call today we
got wheeler Walker we got [ __ ] J
Lawson next week promoting this [ __ ]
show that's great
about comics at the beginning with the
tapes it should it seems interesting as
[ __ ] you know I don't like none of that
[ __ ] but that [ __ ] blew me away I think
that's a brilliant idea I won't even
give it up anymore so stay tuned
[ __ ] but this is it it's the
Tuesday morning podcast let me just hear
me out for a second just because I got
you're right listen the holidays
accompany you all look sharp you bump
into some chick at the office you take a
back you want those little white
underwear with a little skid marks and
stuff
it's 2017 you gotta help your underwear
game me and these makes you feel good me
undies makes feel good on these your
butt will be proud to wear tell be the
most comfortable player on the way
you'll ever own and to check out
yourself go to me on these calm right
now
with tons of styles and patterns to
choose from for both men and ladies me
undies will have the perfect fit for any
personality the me undies feeling is
unmatched because they they use a
naturally soft fabric that is three
times softer than cotton now for a
limited time only check out me on these
first ever glow-in-the-dark print lights
out are you kidding
glow-in-the-dark are you kidding me or
what
why not update your underwear draw and
glow at the same time and if your
underwear is in your thing me undies
also makes the softest socks in the
world I got a pair for your house Lee
I'm sorry I just forget I put them in
the closet thank you
but no no no listen as far as you guys
know I've been working with me on this
now for a few years is it because this
or that no it's because I personally
wear oh well I go to jujitsu
they're the underwear choice for me I
don't like being sweaty and me undies
the mold or the fabric it takes that
sweat away from your skin you have no
you have no idea look how I'm go I'm a
fat dude all my own underwear we're
stretching out not me undies me undies
are still ticking so do myself and
yourself a favor go to me on these coms
last Joey right now they're gonna be the
most comfortable pair on the way you'll
ever own so right now to check out the
whole collection for yourself go to me
on these comm slash Joey what I'm gonna
do is this cuz you know I love you
people I know how long it'll look good
and I want your nuts to be fresh for the
holidays and right you know me and your
little monkeys ladies I want that to be
fresh too and me undies will do that for
you but to get the party started goes
all I'm gonna do I'm gonna get you 20%
off the best and softest underwear and
socks you'll ever own free shipping and
you ready for this one 100% satisfaction
guaranteed to go that's how I roll
people so do yourself a favor go to me
on these calm slash Joey
that's me undies calm
/ Joey I'm giving you my personal
guarantee you're gonna love how they
feel
you're gonna love how they look you're
gonna tweet me and go Joey
you're a [ __ ] Savage go to me on this
comm slash Joey number two listen like I
said the holidays I come in you want it
you got to work force employees you want
to get rid of you no I'm saying you got
dead skin you want to start the year off
good you're looking to hire people
you're looking to upgrade your business
whether it's small or large you're
looking to make them all right but you
need great talent for your business but
you're short on time you don't have to
you know you don't have to get lost in a
huge stack of resumes to find your
perfect hire all you need to do is have
the right tools smarter tools so if
you're hiring and you know that quality
highest keep your business moving
forward but you also know it could take
a lot of time to find the right
candidate uncle Joey's here for you
ready for this do you like it do you
like like this with zip recruiter you
can post your job over though one
hundred of the web's leading job boards
with one click so you can rest easy
knowing your job is being seen by the
right candidates and that's what you
want then zip recruiter puts it small
smart matching technology to work for
you actively notifying quality
candidates about your job within minutes
of posting so you receive the best
possible matches and bad there you have
it that's why zip recruit is different
unlike the other hiring Zayat sites the
zip recruiter doesn't depend on the
right candidates finding you it finds
them you can even get a head start on
the interview process by adding
screening questions to your job both to
help identify the most qualified
candidates so you don't have to waste
time sorting to a stack a resumes for
the perfect fit that means time not one
to 80% of employees who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day again
one day that means you're saving time
you're more productive you're happier
that's a zip record doofy and it's easy
to use a zip recruited dashboard lets
you manage your hiring process from
start to finish
all in one place listen zip recruiter is
the smartest way to hire find out today
why zip recruiter has been used by
growing businesses of all sizes
industries to find the most qualified
job candidates with the immediate
results and right now my listeners my
family can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right free gratis go to
zip recruiter calm right now slash
church CH you are CH that zip record
calm slash Church one more time
zip recruit calm slash shirts listen
they're gonna save your time and then
get your best possible candidate
I want to thank the prakruti and I want
to thank me on these once again I want
to thank my man Cassius Morris and I
want to thank my little brother Lisa at
for making the podcast possible all I
want to thank you savage is for
supported all right I'll see you
[ __ ] Wednesday and I'll see the
rest of your [ __ ] Thursday
night at Lexington Comedy Broadway
Lexington Kentucky [ __ ] but
don't go Louisville
let's do this [ __ ] do this [ __ ] have a
great day man stay black uncle Joey love
you